bonsoir bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu le
journal de la rédaction pour ne rien
manquer de l'actualité locale voici tout
de suite les titres de ce 19 mai ce
samedi quatre associations de riverains
de l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école
manifester contre les nuisances
aériennes il réclame deux plages de
silence les élus sont venus et sophie
deux mois après son élection le maire
ump de bois d'arcy impose un nouveau
style la page est définitivement tournée
la ville était définie par le socialiste
claude juillet depuis trois mandats
il est l'invité de ce journal le
festival de cannes ses films ses stars
saisi blinois en partenariat avec radio
sensations découvrez toute la semaine
comédiens réalisateurs financeurs qui
actuellement participent à cette
célébration du 7e il est 18 heures si
vous nous suivez en direct ce lundi il
ya quelques instants vient de se
terminer la première conférence de
presse de didier deschamps à
clairefontaine l'équipe de france de
football prend ses quartiers dans son
centre d'entraînement yvelinois sont
déjà arrivés hugo lloris mamadou sakho
ou encore mathieu debuchy l'entraîneur
est revenu sur la blessure du week end
celle du gardien steve mandanda forfait
pour ce mondial
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
la première conférence de presse du
champion du monde 98 sur place patrick
jacques de dixmude
je suis triste pour lui ses camarades
aussi c'est des choses qui peuvent
arriver malheureusement et là
aujourd'hui
voilà c c c'était injouable pour lui de
de pouvoir espérer être disponible par
rapport à ce qui nous attend donc les
bleus sélectionnés qui se prépare dans
les yvelines ils disputeront le 27 mai
un premier match de préparation contre
la norvège au stade de france
une centaine de riverains à manifester
ce samedi sur l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école contre les nuisances aériennes
soutenus dans leur action par des maires
notamment de saint cyr l'école ou encore
de plaisir ils réclament des plages de
silence le week end de nouvelles
trajectoires également pour les engins
catherine château est clair qu'en bien
sylvaine harley habite depuis 87 à
villepreux elle est venue manifester ce
samedi matin à l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école pour dénoncer les nuisances
aériennes
je suis juste au dessus de la montée de
la descente sur l'aérodrome de sacyr
donc voilà le départ c'est à 19h45 le
matin toutes les deux minutes et le
retour le soir à 23h30 quand on est
arrivé il n'y avait pas d'avion
voilà donc que petit à petit ça s'est
infiltrée nous avons eu des hélicoptères
qui sont venus s'imposer ici comme elle
ils sont une centaine des riverains mais
également des élus des communes alentour
ci a eu la présence aujourd'hui
deux des mères de quatre communes et des
adjoints d'autres communes
c'est quand même que l'exaspération ses
vingt ans de combat et surtout 20 ans de
l'inexistence complète et totale de
dialogue avec les usagers de l'aérodrome
il est important que les habitants qui
vivent les nuisances
isolés les uns des autres est l'occasion
de se retrouver surtout de montrer leur
détermination leur détermination et leur
revendication dans ce courrier qu'ils
adressent à la direction générale de
l'aviation civile les associations de
riverains réclament de nouvelles
trajectoires et surtout des plages de
silence le week-end c'est à peu près 600
mouvements par jour donc vous imaginez
que vous avez un avion toutes les 2 à 3
minutes qui passent soit au dessus de
vos habitations soit à proximité de vos
habitations mais avec un vacarme
infernal
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas entendus
du tout sur nos revendications
donc en fait les pilotes ne veulent pas
adhérer à ces plages de silence pour des
raisons évidentes parce qu'on les
gênerait dans leur activité qui je le
rappelle est une activité de loisir les
associations de riverains regroupe à ce
jour deux mille adhérents et malgré la
petite centaine de manifestants présents
samedi matin ils continuent le combat un
combat de plusieurs années
la direction générale de l'aviation
civile jointe par téléphone confirme
connaître les attentes de ses habitants
des revendications qui seront une
nouvelle fois étudiés lors d'une
commission consultative qui doit se
réunir en juin et où seront rassemblés
les principaux acteurs du dossier
à une semaine des élections européennes
debout la république vous allez le voir
a pris de la hauteur en affichant son
message dans le ciel des yvelines le
parti de nicolas dupont aignan qui
espère progresser dans un contexte
eurosceptique qui lui est plutôt
favorable à heymans et jérémy et braz un
sens est assis sont allés rencontrer la
tête de liste pour la région ile de
france
dominique jamet tête de liste de debout
la république aux élections européennes
pour lui le scrutin du 25 mai se résume
à un choix très simple devenir un état
fédéré ou conserver ses prérogatives
d'état nation pour le vice président du
parti dirigé par nicolas dupont aignan
la réponse ne fait aucun doute au regard
de son programme renégocier les traités
qui ont privé progressivement la france
de la maîtrise de son budget de la
maîtrise de sa monnaie de la maîtrise de
ces lois et de la maîtrise de ses
frontières
un discours aux accents anti européen
proche de celui tenu par le front
national
pourtant dominique jamet la sueur si le
parti de marine le pen forme un groupe
parlementaire
il ne le rejoindra pas que ce soit avec
alternatifs hedge fund partie l'islam
né en allemagne que ce soit avec le
parti d'anouar que ce soit avec lui
occupe avec éventuellement des
mouvements grecque avec qui nous sommes
nous attendons du finlandais
nous espérons pouvoir constituer un
groupe qui ne sera pas le même que celui
qui se réalisera autour du front
national prendre ses distances avec le
fn et prendre de la hauteur dans lequel
yvelinois voilà les moyens de debout la
république pour s'affirmer aux élections
européennes en 2009
le parti avait réalisé 2 44% des
suffrages en ile de france
à noter aussi le meeting à venir dans
les yvelines de la liste l'alternative
conduite par le modem et lui dès demain
les candidats en ile-de-france marielle
de sarnez jean marie cavada ou encore
chantal jouanno et tiendront une réunion
publique à l'université interâges à
versailles dès 19h et puis pas de
meeting mais un déplacement sur le
terrain pour olivier besancenot est tête
de liste npa nouveau parti
anticapitaliste également dans la région
le 20 mai il sera au côté des salariés
de psa à poissy de renault à guyancourt
mais aussi du personnel de l'hôpital de
poissy avant de terminer ce marathon par
un échange avec les grévistes de fébus à
versailles la société de transport en
commun qui je vous le rappelle est
mobilisée depuis plus d'une semaine
nous y reviendrons bien sûr l'europe
dans notre quotidien dernière ligne
droite pas avant le vote pour notre
série explicative signé catherine
plateau le centre d'information europe
direct qui nous présente ce soir le rôle
de l'union dans la législation de la
téléphonie mobile
de manière pratique elle va surtout
limiter la facture téléphonique des
clients parce que alors récemment le
parlement européen a voté ce qu'on
appelle le paquet télécom et ce paquet
télécom contient notamment ce qu'on
appelle la fin du roaming
alors le roaming c'est les frais
d'itinérance 3g quand on est dans un
pays de l'union européenne alors c'est à
dire que par exemple un citoyen qui a un
smartphone qui souhaitent consulter
internet via les réseaux 3g ou la 4g
tout simplement va utiliser son forfait
téléphonique va utiliser sa data or
parfois il arrive assez souvent qu'on
est ce qu'on est et que qu'on explose
qu'on n'est pas le forfait qui est qui
est autorisé et donc notamment quand
vous êtes à l'étranger avant on avait
des surcoûts qui était qui étaient
facturées c'est à dire qu'on avait
l'opérateur local qui facturait la kiffe
acte qui facturait la connexion 3g mais
on avait aussi la période l'opérateur
national qui pouvait aussi récupérer de
l'argent
le parlement européen vient d'interdire
cela malgré l'avis contraire du
gouvernement français c'est
effectivement un plus pour le
consommateur net j'ai entendu des cas
dans l'actualité on avait des personnes
qui avaient pas qu'ils avaient pas
désactivé leur 3g quand il partait à
l'étranger et qui revenait avec des
factures de 1000 2000 3000 euros voire
même dix mille euros dans certains cas
le texte n'est pas encore définitivement
adopté il doit être
validée par les états mais si le texte
est voté en la matière le texte
s'appliquera à tout le monde pour les
opérateurs français
après s'ils veulent contester ils
peuvent toujours tenter une action
devant la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
mais il ya de fortes chances qu'il soit
déboutée parce que tout simplement ça va
être un droit supplémentaire qui est
accordée aux citoyens européens et ça et
la cour de justice n'aime pas revenir
sur les droits des citoyens européens
on reste dans la politique avec l'invité
du jour philippe benassaya bonsoir vous
êtes le maire ump de bois d'arcy élu
pour la première fois à ce poste en mars
ce dernier on va à dresser un bilan de
vos premières actions et ce rapide
questionnaire pour débuter cela concerne
vos engagements de campagne pas de
surprise vous me répondez tout
simplement parfait ou pas fait
éventuellement si c'est en cours
supprimer le projet coeur de ville
bientôt augmenter la fréquence des
transports en commun pas tout de suite
stabiliser les impôts locaux fait
appliquer le service minimum dans les
écoles fait mettre en place un guichet
unique en mairie pour faciliter les
démarches bientôt fin d'année voilà
quelques-unes des propositions vous
aviez fait pendant votre campagne juste
on va revenir sur la fréquence des
transports en commun pour bientôt
oui parce qu'il faut quand même négocié
avec versailles grand parc a réussi avec
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parce qu'on
peut nous sommes entre deux gares la
gare de saint-quentin et la gare de
fontenay donc c'est pas quelque chose je
vous rappelle qu'on est là que depuis
deux mois effectivement fait donc
aujourd'hui le maire de bois d'arcy on
va rentrer un peu plus dans le détail de
vos premiers mois en tant que maire
votre première mesure et l annulation du
projet coeur de ville
pourquoi cette suppression de ce projet
et qui était portée par votre
prédécesseur est ce que c'est une
motivation idéologique
quels sont vos justifications a
justement c'est mes motivations
n'étaient pas idéologique
donc la précédente mandature oui mais là
non non parce que notre projet repose
sur la défense du cadre de vie de
l'environnement et que nous pensons nous
pensons toujours que érigé 400 logements
sur un carrefour c'est suicidaire
suicidaire pour la circulation
suicidaire pour les transports
suicidaire pour les services publics
et c'est suicidaire pour la densité
urbaine dans un carrefour si j'avais la
place de faire 400 logements jeu j'y
réfléchirai
mais sur un carrefour en plus le
carrefour de l'amérique est déjà
totalement saturé c'était une hérésie
quelles solutions emplacement vous
proposez supprimerons donc lors du
prochain conseil municipal du 17 juin
leur part délibération le projet de
coeur de ville et nous allons lancer une
véritable concertation parce que nous
avons nous avions beaucoup de choses à
redire sur cette concertation qui avait
eu dans les années passées où la vie des
arts si ça n'avait pas été pris en
compte c'est ça qui était dangereux
là nous ferons une vraie concertation
avec des artisiens pour pouvoir bâtir
ensemble un projet plus environnemental
plus bas plus doux en matière de hauteur
et plus plus vert en coeur de ville
comme l'on croyait définir votre style
de gestion évolutionnaire faire table
rase du passé
non c'est ça non non non révolutionnaire
non faire table rase du passé je vois
les références non mais non non non ce
qui nous apparaît nécessaire de faire
c'est le pragmatisme c'est à dire
répondre précisément aux attentes des
arcisien loin des idéologies est loin
des querelles politiciennes c'est qu'ils
étaient souvent le cas dans le passé
malheureusement avec toutes les
divisions qui est notre objectif à nous
c'est de répondre aux attentes des
arcizac trachomatis mme réalisme sans
révolution mais avec évolution
un mot sur vos rapports justement avec
votre prédécesseur claude juillet
apparemment lui est en conflit avec son
ancien collègue ancien adjoint olivier
colo secrétaire de la section locale du
parti socialiste il a été très abattu
après sa défaite est ce que vous
échangez aujourd'hui avec lui sachant
qu'ils siègent dans votre position
puisqu'il avance nous on reconnaît
souvent les gens dans la défaite j'ai je
découvre monsieur viguier dans la
défaite il est en conflit avec tout le
monde avec avec ses propres amis ses
propres son propre parti son propre
courant politique aggrave aura plaisir à
écouter lorsqu'on ne veut pas
reconnaître sa défaite et faire le
travail d'autocritique que nous avons
fait nous en 2008 quand nous avons perdu
nous avions là pour le coup fait table
rase du passé et reconstruit une
véritable alternative aux renards citant
qu'il est dans cette dans cette violence
un peu et dense est dans ce ressentiment
dans cette amertume ce qui bloquera
beaucoup d'années le renouvellement dans
son courant politique
on en revient à votre action nous avons
demandé à quelques-uns de vos amis est
administré par don à ce qu'il pensait de
vos premières décisions satisfait qu'il
a qui ne fasse pas le centre ville
voilà maintenant le restant il faut
attendre je ne le connais pas ah oui
pour le centre-ville c'est formidable il
voulait faire des tours et on était
content
les raisons personnelles sont elles sont
faciles quand vous invitez bois d'arcy
là c'est la saturation de carrefour et
construire 400 logements dans un
carrefour qui est saturé matin et soir
vous mettez un quart d'heure vingt
minutes deux fois pour passer je suis
vraiment désolé en fait pour construire
400 logements au coeur de ville alors
que la ville manque le parking n'y a
rien du tout j'ai cru entendre dire
qu'il ne voulait pas l'appliquer ce que
je cautionne complètement on rentrera en
dernière année de maternelle je vois pas
du tout l'intérêt pour elles d'aller à
l'école le mercredi matin
moi je ne travaille pas le mercredi donc
avec ou sans classes de toute façon
c'est pas vraiment gérable pour
quelqu'un qui travaille pas le mercredi
donc dans tous les cas je travaillerai
pas donc ça n'arrange en rien les
parents et je suis pas du tout sûr que
ça ronge ses enfants bien au contraire
quand les idées sont bonnes maintenant
moi j'attends j'attends de voir plus un
peu plus tard bilan les gens attendent
en tout cas ils sont fins prêts pour le
projet coeur de ville on a aussi entendu
une mère de famille évoqué cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires alors ça n'a pas
été initiée par votre prédécesseur en
tout cas lui avait prévu de de la mettre
en place à la rentrée
en revanche ce n'est pas votre cas il
n'y aura pas de réforme des rythmes
scolaires à la rentrée en septembre pour
un bois d'arcy
alors juste un petit mot avant de
rentrer dans les rythmes scolaires judy
secondes
l'élection ne s'est pas faite uniquement
sur le coeur de ville je sais que
c'était le grand projet ferroviaire plus
mais absolument absolument mais
lorsqu'on fait un vrai micro-trottoir
plus long c'est normal vous n'avez pas
vous allez d'autres villes à faire il y
avait d'autres considérations qui jouer
mais c'est vrai on va dire que le coeur
de ville et et le l'axé prioritaire du
programme il y avait bien d'autres
choses qui fait que qui font qu'on a
gagné sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires lorsqu'on a des convictions il
faut les faut les appliquer j'étais
contre cette réforme je suis toujours
contre cette réforme je pense quelle
fatigue des enfants elle n'est pas
financée en plus et en plus compte tenu
des marges de manoeuvre des de notre
budget qui sont totalement nuls
il est presque il est totalement
impossible de d'appliquer cette réforme
qui va coûter cher alors soit on
augmente les impôts pour appliquer cette
réforme dont on ne sait même pas si elle
a un impact positif sur les enfants
comme un plaisir comme elle en cours
vous n'appliquerait pas ça je reporte
donc pour la rentrée 2014 2015 cette
réforme des rythmes secours autant vous
me dites que vous reportez mais le
responsable de l'académie que nous avons
rencontrés à quelques jours on nous
disait qu'il le mettrait en place
lui-même la réforme si les maires ne
voulait pas l'appliquer mais on est vrai
les horaires et si les maires ne veulent
toujours pas appliqué les nouveaux
horaires ce sera au préfet eh bien on
verra à ce moment là on verra vraiment
attachés à l'école comme si les préfètes
demande à ce que les écoles seront en
tout cas on iront le nous irons le plus
loin possible dans nos convictions
ensuite on verra s'il faut discuter
parce que cette méthode là de l'état
tout puissant qui impose à une commune
malgré les marges de manoeuvre nuls dont
je parle une réforme dont on n'a
absolument pas des résultats au niveau
des enfants
je trouve ça intolérable je trouve ça
totalitaire pardonnez moi l'expression
voilà donc moi je suis sûrement mon
report de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires je suis maire de ceux de cette
ville de bonheur si j'ai délibéré en ce
sens où je reste là dessus on gère
horaire rien n'a été déposée de votre
part ont remercié ont reporté quelle que
soit la décision et on verra ensuite
comment ça évoluera parce que si les
préfets de bien sûr et on verra on verra
à ce moment-là je reviendrai vous en
parlais tout à fait philippe benassaya
ce matin nos confrères du parisien qui
revenait sur les budgets vous l'avez
évoqué d'ailleurs à la baisse dans
certaines communes vous en faites partie
vous avez décidé de faire des économies
400000 euros d'économies comme vous
faites tersant
non alors il ya eu une petite erreur
dans le ses 4000 non non non non non on
a une petite erreur dans l'analyse faite
non pas par vous si en fait il nous
n'avons enfin versailles grand parc nous
verser 400 mille euros la commune de
l'agglomération à laquelle vous
appartenez
elle ne nous verse +77 cette subvention
qui est très technique un pardonner mais
on va pas rentrer dans les détails
donc c'est vrai que nous allons faire un
budget en 2015 avec ses quatre cent
mille euros de moins à cela vous
rajoutez les baisses des taux d' des
dotations de l'état qui sont importantes
pour chaque ville et puis quelques
entreprises qui vont disparaître ceux de
bois d'arcy donc avec encore une fois
des marges de manoeuvre très très très
étroite
nous allons faire un budget très
rigoureux parce que compte tenu de ce
que je vais dire que plus de 400 milles
plus le reste il va falloir trouver
trouver les écoutez je vais vous dire
quelque chose lorsqu'on est en crise et
lorsque l'état diminue ses aides aux
communes
eh bien il faut réduire le train de vie
des communes lorsque vous dans votre
ménage ou dans votre famille vous n'avez
plus les moyens de sortir vous n'allez
plus au restaurant vous n'allez plus au
cinéma et bien pour une commune c'est à
peu près la même chose il faudra se
serrer un peu la ceinture
il faudra que les indiens non je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas estimé mais il faudra
que les ars isa comprenne qu'il va
falloir réduire la voilure à moins
d'augmenter les impôts mais je ne
souhaite pas augmenter les impôts et
faire peser la crise sur le dos des
arcis donc vos priorités
les économies s'offrant que les
économies se feront sur le train de vie
comme je voulais dit c'est-à-dire
l'événementiel la communication la
culture est souvent cité nos confrères
du parisien évoque la culture
absolument je ne vois pas seulement
l'achat des livres des cd l'action
culturelle la médiathèque alors il y
avait 1 % des choses qui peuvent faire
peur aux usagers je comprends mais vous
savez où il faut faire parler les
chiffres et pas les commenter pour
l'achat des livres il y avait à peu près
50 mille euros d'achats de livres par an
bien on va peut-être réduire de moitié
25000 on va pas voilà c'est pas
dramatique d'avoir un budget de 25 mille
euros pour acheter des livres plutôt que
de 50 milles en temps de crise c'est pas
grave c'est pas dramatique mais nous
faisons un geste pour réduire justement
ce train de vie là
il n'y a pas que la culture à
l'événementiel c'est à dire tous les
événements il ya aussi la communication
ma propre communication sert à tout ce
qui est en plus de ce que nous ne
bougerons pas c'est à dire bien sûr la
solidarité les seniors les affaires
sociales etc qui sont là pour le coup
prioritaire un dernier mot très rapide
pour conclure votre regard sur les
européennes l'abstention s'annonce très
forte ou l'ordi 3 aujourd'hui à vos
administrés pour voter dimanche
valérie pécresse qui disait aujourd'hui
au figaro donc la secrétaire général
délégué l'ump qui s'occupe de l'ump
également dans les yvelines
elles disaient les listes défouloir sont
inutiles vont affaiblir la france où il
faut pas confondre d'élections l'europe
c'est très important pour nous au
quotidien c'est très difficile
d'expliquer cela nos administrés parce
qu'ils ne voient pas l'europe au
quotidien et pourtant l'europe est
présente partout à une incidence jusque
dans les commerces sarah une incidence
si je peux vous le dire maintenant que
je suis maire c'est ça a une incidence
énormément il faut voter utile
voilà quelle que soit votre vote mais il
faut voter utile il faut éviter
justement de voter pour des listes anti
européenne anti euro anti-tout qui
profite des européennes pour se défouler
est revenu en plateau la nuit des musées
nous poursuivons ce journal plus de 2
millions de visiteurs à travers l'europe
qui partagent ce moment culturel la
nocturne la gratuité est de mise et le
plus souvent des événements sont
proposés des concerts des performances à
saint quentin en yvelines le musée de la
ville a fait le pari du hip hop
yolaine 13 et julien leroy
c'est parti pour une soirée rythmée par
les cultures urbaines
à l'occasion de la nuit des musées à
saint quentin en yvelines graff pochoir
ou encore breakdance étaient au
programme
c'est très ludique pour les enfants et
tout donc pour salir nos futurs mur mais
plus bas j'ai trouvé ça sympa parce
qu'ils s'éclatent quoi c'est toujours un
plaisir de voir des artistes libres mais
des gens ils voient ce sont des
taxes est pas bon et c'est hélas ça
montre vraiment que c'est pas uniquement
un graffiti ya quelque chose derrière il
ya une démarche artistique un une
véritable démarche que les artistes ont
tenté de mettre en avant à travers les
différents ateliers proposés
d'autant plus que nous fêtons cette
année les 30 ans du hip hop sur le
territoire un anniversaire important
pour la jeune génération d'artistes pour
moi c'est quelque chose de très
important parce qu'il n'avait pas dix
truites vraiment de structures encore
j'aime pas trop encore jeune j'ai 23 ans
mais on a la possibilité de pouvoir
maintenant travailler avec des mairies
des choses comme ça donc c'est une très
belle évolution que ça puisse continuer
comme ça il ya une bonne tradition hip
hop dans la ville c'est vrai
et j'espère que cette tradition va se
perpétuer au fil du temps on est là pour
la supporter on veut montrer aux gens
que qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour faire du
hip hop on peut commencer à tout âge et
que c'est surtout dans la tête
mais quand il ya la volonté on peut
faire ce qu'on veut un message qui
semble être bien passé
après quelques hésitations ses jeunes
initié selon ces fonds le show la relève
est assurée
la nuit des musées autre style c'était
aussi à versailles ce week-end le
château qui proposait une visite de nuit
un moment magique julien leroy a
recueilli les impressions de quelques
privilégiés
et vous pensez que c'était important
pour le show de versailles ce soit ou
pas alors moi je suis versailles est
donc c'est vrai que voilà je le vois
tous les jours mais pour autant je suis
lassé soir donc oui c'est important et
ça permet d'appréhender un peu le musée
sans forcément le passer la journée là
bas quoi donc c'était c'était assez
intéressant c'est magnifique
moi je l'aï vu le jour là c'est encore
plus beau lanières on est dans une autre
ambiance on va dire plus à dire
ésotérique mais presque
on dit on va peut-être voir marie
antoinette un voile passé dans ce
château pourquoi pas quoi quelques
hallucinations château de versailles ce
week end culture toujours mais direction
cannes le festival s'est ouvert il ya
quelques jours et au milieu des stars on
trouve aussi des jeunes originaires des
mureaux membres du jury d'une autre
compétition en avril dernier le festival
des juniors dont les yvelines qui
propose long métrage exposition dans le
nord du département ils vivent à leur
tour aujourd'hui
en récompense de leur engagement un rêve
dans la cité du 7e art c'est un
reportage de nicolas kirillovitch pour
radio sensations assisté de franck david
ils ont entre 9 et 12 ans ils réalisent
leur rêve venir au festival de cannes
julien madeleine laurine et leurs
copains sont les gagnants cette année du
festival des juniors des mureaux un
concours qui fait appel depuis presque
quinze ans au talent de critiques de
jeune fille blinois le principe c'est
une action d'éducation à l'image qui se
déroule sur un territoire les mureaux
verneuil-sur-seine et et vernouillet le
lan et qui consiste en un concours de
critiques en novembre décembre
ensuite à partir de ce concours ont
choisi un jeune jury
ensuite en avril on organise un festival
avec un vrai festival 1 35 films dont
neuf films en compétition et ce sont les
jeunes qui ont gagné le concours de
critique qui qui représente le jeune
jury ils choisissent le grand prix du
festival des juniors et ensuite pour les
récompenser on les emmène à cannes deux
à trois mille participants et seulement
10 euros et lui le festival des juniors
demande un vrai talent critique sous le
feu des projecteurs pour cette édition
qui s'est déroulée en avril dernier
allemagne à ce film aborde avec humour
les problèmes d'une famille turque
expatriés en allemagne
au programme du séjour cannois
projection de film balade sur la
croisette et on ville et puis chaque
soir la montée des marches
un spectacle glamour avec des stars qui
ne semble pas déplaire à nos critiques
en herbe
bien au contraire moi j'adore kahn parce
que j'adore le soleil et c'est très
agréable toujours et puis la montée des
marches
évidemment j'ai pas connu enfin j'ai pas
reconnu de personnes très connues mais
c'est toujours une ambiance un peu
spécial donc c'est spécial je savais
qu'avec des stars qui qui montait les
marches mais moi je pensais qu'elle
viendrait signer des autographes aux
gens et de sa vie en fait non bah je
connais aucun acteur alors c'était un
peu compliqué ce qui m'amuse en fait
c'est ça on nettoie avec tous nos amis
et on peut bien jouer ensemble rigoler
et voilà six mois que quand on est tout
seul quand on est tous allés et bientôt
ce seront peut-être eux qui monteront
les marches du palais car pour certains
enfants devenus grands
le festival des juniors des mureaux n'a
été qu'une simple étape on a monté
depuis un concours de courts métrages
on a des jeunes qui se sont lancés dans
des dans des études de cinéma donc c'est
vrai que sur le territoire ça a quand
même mobilisé par mais à papa pas mal de
monde et déclenché quand même des
leaders des passions et des et des
envies d'aller un peu plus loin on va
dire l'année prochaine c'est un film
anglais qui sera soumis aux critiques
des plus jeunes des mureaux et des
villes alentour believe un film sur le
football
un thème probablement d'une plus grande
source d'inspiration pour les garçons
téléphiles radio sensations qui
s'associent pour la durée du festival de
cannes on retrouvera sur place nicolas
kirillovitch le veinard jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine prochain journal en direct
à 18h mardi vous retrouverez catherine
où l'atome quant à moi je donne rendez
vous dès 18h15 pour le second débat de
ces européennes sur notre antenne ps ump
et front national europe ecologie les
verts pour échanger sur la crise
économique et l'euroscepticisme
également excellente soirée sur notre
antenne